all right
edgar yes sir edgar where'd you grow up
where are you from originally
i'm originally franklin virginia i've
been out here since i came out here when
i was five years old
and you grew up with your neighborhood i
grew up and watched the [ __ ] and
gardens
tell me about your childhood you had
both parents as a kid or not no um
just my mother my dad is um
he was still in franklin virginia me
my mom and my sister came out here
and it was just just me and my sister
and how would how do you describe your
childhood excuse me how was your
childhood
my childhood well
the best way i can put it is i grew up
in a um
violent neighborhood um
they had just about anything he wanted
as far as drugs
liquor whatever my surroundings
was uh gang banging and
[Music]
you know downhill life
and you uh you stayed home with your mom
until
how long i say you know my mom's at
about 12 years old
i ran away from home i
came downtown l.a
um i stayed downtown i live for about
three and a half years i went back home
and got in a little trouble i went to
jail
to um juvenile hall juvenile hall
to uh county jail from the county jail
to prison you go to mexico excuse me did
you go to high school
i went to high school for three days
and the reason why the neighborhood i
stayed in
was a game the name of the game was
bounty hunters from the nixon gardens
the school i went to was jordan high
and they had
a project called the jordan downs you
drew it down was crips
and we was bloods and by me being the
blood
they kind of knew my face and i was like
hey what's your name ain't your name
frazier my nickname was faiso
and uh they're like entertaining phrasal
i'm like yeah
they say don't you say the naked gardens
and before
i can answer the question it's like
almost the whole school
was coming towards me which i knew was
bad so i ran
you know like i said it was only for
like three days i said yeah i can
i can go because i was in the wrong
neighborhood the school
school was the wrong neighborhood and
from there
i being homeless
still and drugs or alcohol came in the
picture for you when
alcohol i was about
nine years old when i started drinking
and what started me drinking was
my uncles my aunties used to always come
over
to my mom's house and they used to play
cars
gamble and drink my uncle my favorite
uncle he drunk one five
squishy he got um bacardi
bacardi was like um one five
one and usually people would drink it
back with coke
my uncle he would drink it by itself
um he was my favorite uncle and
one day he came over picked me up
took me with him and that's when i
started drinking with my uncle
and at home with your mom she was into
drugs or alcohol
yes she was in drugs alcohol
and it would be times where she
did have what she wanted and
she would check it out on me and my
sister
and i felt like she didn't care about me
why should i stay here and i ran away
from home
but uh drugs had a lot to do with me
running away too
because i was like my mom to a certain
extent you know when
i can get what i wanted i would steal
stuff man
take this stuff didn't belong to me and
they would
bring a problem to my house and
the best way i knew how to get it was to
run away and they started me going to
jail
what kind of stuff are you getting into
at that at that point
well gang banging females
anything i could get into basically the
prison
time you did was for what taking
uh um taking stuff from somebody stole
them properly
um breaking into houses breaking into
cars
jacking people you know all kinds of
stupid stuff
you know at that time it wasn't stupid
because
i was under influence and
my mind was basically
i guess on one thing and it was getting
drugs
and i didn't have no job so it was only
one way i knew how to get it
and that was you know catch somebody
back turn
and take from one yeah that was crack
cocaine that you were
chasing that was yes yes
and do you have kids of your own no i
had no kids
um what really striked me to crack
ukraine
was my mom um she was smoking
and uh i wanted to see what it was like
you know i went and got some
my mom had to choose so i brought it
back to her
and she like looked at me kind of crazy
but she wanted some
too so i started smoking with my moms
and
i was getting hot with my mom's for a
long time until she passed away
how much prison time have you done in
all the most prison time i've done
was two and a half years but a total
total
two and a half years oh so so not that
much prison time
no it was basically in and out because i
was on parole
okay by me being on parole when i got
out
it was certain things that um i had to
do
i was still getting high so
i didn't report
because when i report they would test me
they would give me a drug test
and i know i'm dirty so
it's like i'm turning myself in okay
i felt like this at that time
if i got a report or turn myself in
i'm not gonna do it okay your job is to
either
catch me or i turn myself
in and i was gonna turn myself in so
anytime i got stopped
by not reporting you know they would
they would take me in
that's the only way they would take me
in and uh there would be a violation
of parole because i didn't report so
they would take me back to i
had to go back to the prison for a
certain amount of time eight months six
months
you know and you've been living on the
street for how long now
i'm 56 i've been on the street since i
was 12.
and today you are living in a tent yes
down here in skid row
yes right down the street and what do
you do for money now
i rush cars i watch windows
i sweep i um do clean up
you know you're still using crack yes
have you ever been clean only time was
clean
when i got locked up and you get out and
you eventually just go back
when i get out my first stop is the
liquor store
because i mean i i i really really
like like the drinking i like
the feelings that he gave me you know
and
i just it was something i enjoyed when
you when you were a child did you have
what kind of dreams did you have for
your life did you do you have any
thing that you i wanted to be um i
wanted to write write books
i i like to write poems that's what i
did that i started to write poems and i
was locked up
you know i write real good porn um
right things that comes to my mind
things on my mind
things i see in people other people
you know i like i like to move around a
lot
have you ever been in love you know
yes almost every female i've been really
happy
you know but it was just one particular
girl that
i was in love i would do anything for
anything if she asked me to rob a bank i
probably would
how do you think outsiders as they drive
through skid row
what their what their impression is of
people that are living on the street
like you do
oh i don't know how to describe that um
i've seen people that uh
in their mind call themselves pretty
good and
they look down on us on the people
who lived on the streets and um
i met this one guy that was on the
streets
and about a week after
i was at the gas station where i hustled
at and he drove up to the gas station
and uh mercedes-benz this guy got a
chance and he was like you know what
he said only reason i was on the street
i wanted
to see what the street light was about
he said man i got two cars i got a wife
i got a family
i got my own business and
he said here the guy ahead of me like
500
just say just from being my friend not
looking down on me and not judging me
and it kind of like it blew my mind
you know he said yeah he said i just
want to see what the street life
was about because a lot of people look
down on you guys
and won't get you nothing and they turn
their nose up when they walk past us
and it hurts you know
i didn't go to school i went to school
but i didn't go to class
you know and uh it's a big difference
you know i don't look at myself no
different than anybody else
i don't judge nobody you know
it's it's an old saying everything look
good
ain't always good everything looked bad
and also bad and as bad as it looked
you know what do you think attracts
people to this
street life i mean the the lack of
responsibility you think and
either never have to work you never have
to pay taxes you never have to do
anything though
real but street to me
street life is
people there's in the drugs
okay um
and just about everybody that's on the
streets
is entered into something okay
um like where i'm living at right now um
i feel safer here i call this my home
the reason why i call it my home because
it's it's my surroundings i feel better
and safer here than being around
somebody that
work every day they don't drink
it's a different feeling it's a
different life
so we call we call this home because
it's street life we
we do what we want to do um
it's just different from a
person in beverly hills hollywood
you know you feel like you belong here
yes
because if i if even though i'm doing
the same thing
if i was staying in hollywood or beverly
hills
i wouldn't feel right because nobody
ain't too many people up there in
hollywood
beverly hills do what we do and they
they feel but they went to school
graduated you know got job
they're better than us and
i wouldn't i wouldn't feel like you know
here
i don't have to hide anything from
anybody as far as you know what i do
you know um i like to keep them from
nobody
because everybody is doing the same
thing doing something
in the in that um area do you think
you'll be down here the rest of your
life
excuse me you think you'll be down here
the rest of your life um
i'm not for sure to a certain extent i'm
not really
worried about it
i used to think about living and dying
okay and more and more i think about it
you know i think in
me my personal thought is we came here
to do two things
we came here to live and to die
one day isn't it it's not no telling
when we gonna pass away
or whatever but one day we all gotta go
so if if it's my time to
ain't nothing going to stop me from
going because um you came to the air and
died and it's going to happen
one way or not one way or another is
going to happen
and sometimes i feel in my mind yet
even if i do pass away
i pass away to another
world something different
you know and i said if it happened it
happened
you know i hate to see people that's
close to me or anybody really you know
pass away
you know but it's it's got to happen
it's going to happen
i mean it's it's going to it's
you can't get around it you can't get
around it's going to happen
so if you're getting high and not
getting high you die you still going
all right edgar thank you so much for
sharing your story no problem
good luck with everything thank you
thank you thank you
you